[موسيقى]
في الثاني عشر من شباط فبراير عام
1998 نقلت اخبار من الجنوب عن تحطم
الطائره
57 من القيادات السياسيه والعسكريه ووفاه
الزبير محمد صالح نائب رئيس الجمهوريه
والرجل الثاني في الدوله لتستغل الحادثه
ربما في سياق الحرب الدعائيه بين نظام
الانقاذ وخصومه
منهم نفر كريم على راسهم الاخ العزيز
الفريق الزبير محمد صالح النائب الاول
لرئيس الجمهوريه
الذي صاحبنا في هذه الثوره المباركه
اعدادا وتنفيذا وقياده
وظلت سيرته هذه السنوات
يعمل في اخلاص ونكران ذات ولاكثر من عقدين
ظل الغموض الذي يحيط بحادثه تحطم الطائره
حاضرا وبقوه في ذاكره السودانيين وروايات
لا تنفصل عن بيئه السودان المليئه
بالصراعات وحوادث الطائرات المتكرره
سعينا خلال هذا التحقيق لرصد اللحظات
الاخيره للطائره 32
وتحطمها في مدينه الناصر جنوب السودان
والوقوف على حقيقه ما جرى داخل الطائره
وملابسات سقوطها في نهر الصوباط هل كان
حادثا عربيا ام اغتيالا مدبرا
[موسيقى]
وترقق في في السلم الكليه الحربيه واخذ كل
الدورات الحربيه واشتغل في كل مناطق
السودان اشتغل في الشرق والقريب كان في
حديث كثير سنه 88 او سنه 89 علم هنالك
محاوله انقلابيه وكان واحد من هذه
المحاولات كان متهم فيها شهيد الزبير وكان
تم اعتقاله قبال يومين ثلاثه من 30 يونيو
لحد 30 يونيو
برز الزبير على مسرح الاحداث في السودان
عندما تمكن من تحريك قوات الاسناد من جبل
الاولياء لدعم قوات الانقلاب رغم انه كان
حينها معتقلا ليصبح بعد ذلك نائب رئيس
مجلس قياده الثوره والوزراء والنائب الاول
لرئيس الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
لم يكن الوضع السوداني نهايه التسعينيات
في احسن احواله صراع بين الشمال والجنوب
وعلاقات اقليميه معقده بينما كان الزبير
محمد صالح يسبح عكس التيار
السودان في عهد الانغاز وبداياتها كان
مهددا في وحدته
كان محاصرا في حدوده الناس يبحثون عن من
ينقذ
[موسيقى]
فلعلي اقول ان الزبير كان ضالتهما التي
تلقاه في الفاشل بعد شويه الزبير تلقاه في
القهوه في
التخريج بتاع بتاع بتاع بتاع الخدمه
الوطنيه المعسكرات الخدمه كلها
في اغلب
ولذلك
كان زول حركه تامه ما خلينا محل الحمد لله
مشينا اليوم جوا الغابه مشينا لهم في
الخارج مشينا اليوم
محبوبا
اصبح مؤثرا
سحب البساط من كل من كان في عهده من الغاز
كان سبب زياره الى الناصر
انه
في
ذلك العام 1998 حصل تمرد
ولذلك
كانت الحكومه تريد ان تثبت
السلام ولذلك
دعت اطراف السلام في زيارات الى عدد من
المناطق في علي النيل وفي بحر الغزال وكنا
من الذين
كانت الزياره بقياده النائب الاول للرئيس
زبير محمود صالح
لنا انا ماشي جنوب
هتمشوا معايا فحممشي من هنا
من بور هنيجي ريان
عندنا
تاني يوم الصباح نتحرك الى الناصر
من الناصف ما احنا راجعين نطلع طوال من
هيك لعداريل من عداريل الرنك
بيلاقونا
هناخد عربيات من الى الخرطوم وكان معنا
عدد من هؤلاء يا
ربان موسى المكور واخرين يعني
وطيب طيب شيخه كنا في طائره واحده ريال
قاعي
وذهبنا الى بور
التقينا بالمواطنين وشرحنا لهم ظروف
الجديده وضروره التمسك بالسلام
تمكنا من الوصول الى مساعد كابتن الطائره
العقيد انذاك الفاتح خضر والذي نجا من
حادثه تحطم الطائره
يعني تقوم التوت طائرتان
هليكوبتر تقوم
تهبط في ملكات يودون الناصر وبعدين يرجعوا
ملكال الساعه خمسه مساء او خمسه ونص احنا
منتظرين في المسجد بنشوفهم
من الدمازين هبطت الطائره وحدها الطياره
الثانيه قال والله عطله تصنعها الاقلاع
واستكفي الدمازين يعني مندوب من السيد
النائبه الاول والسائره السياره وقالت
سيدنا النبي يطلب احد الطيارين فمشيت
لقيته كان بيخطب واصل في خطبته خمس دقائق
انتهى من الخطبه التفت عليه
يا اخي انت كما تعرف انه اثنين
وتاخذنا الى الناصر ثم العوده الى ما كان
ثم المنطقه الاخرى ثم العوده ثم انتم
تاخذون من
حسب الاشاره اطلع ذاته من العمليات
الحربيه ولكن انا حاسه زرت بور وزرت ملكال
والرجاله دي كان من الاسباب الرئيسيه لها
انا لازم ازور الناصر معي محافظه الناصر
فقلت لها يا سيادتك طيبه الامر اذا حسي
انت فاجئتني بالليل والدنيا داخله على
المساء
والاتصالات ما في موبايلات غير كذا ما نحن
ما في زول جوي قاعد في هناك يعني عليه قال
لو كان ودي مفرزه او ضابط جوي هناك ينزلوه
يكون قاعد عشان يشرف عليكم مناسك جهال
لاسلكي يساعدنا في الهبوط
يقدم لنا اي معلومات يحتاجه لا يورينا
يعني
المهبط واتجاه الريح ولو في اي شيء يعني
يوم عشره
فبراير يوم عشره اثنين ولد لنا اشاره
الاستخبارات مضمون هذه الاشاره يقول انه
ستقوم اليكم شخصيه مهمه بزياره الى محطه
الناصر في يوم 12/2
المطلوب نرجو الافاده بصلاحيه المطار
للهبوط الطائره ان بي 32
ووصف دقيق للمطر قمنا
بالذهاب الميدانيه للمطار لتغيير لتقييمه
وقياسات المطر
فهو كان مدرج ترابي
مرصوف بالخرسانه
يمتد من الشمال للجنوب
بطول على ما اذكر 1470 متر فقاعدين في
المكتب جاءت الاشاره منه انه المهبط 700
متر وعرض ثمانيه امتار
انه يا جماعه احتمال الاشاره او الكاتب ما
سمع كويس ان احتمال الزواج 1700 متر وليس
700 متر جاحدنا نفسنا وعملنا كويس جدا انا
واخونا
العميد كما المبارك رجل معين قائد للطائره
في الوقت ذاك وعملنا بريفي ممتاز جدا جدا
انه احنا نجي نعمل التقرب الاول ونشوف
حاله المحبط ثم نعمل دوره تاني
ونستعد الامور حسب ما راينا عنها بتسمحنا
نهبط واذا شعمنا ان الامور ما بتسمح
نطلب بالعوده الى ملكات
[موسيقى]
في تمام الثامنه صباحا تحركت الطائره التي
تقل الزبير والوفد المرافق له من ملكا
المتجهه الى الناصر التي لم يصل اليها حيا
[موسيقى]
من بين الضحايا كان الفريق الزبير محمد
صالح النائب الاول لرئيس الجمهوريه والذي
كان على راس وفد في رحله وصفها بيان صدر
عقب الحادث بانها تاتي ضمن جهود احلال
السلام في جنوب السودان
لم يعرف احد على وجه التحديد حقيقه ما ادى
لسقوط الطائره في نهر الصوبات
خلال تحقيقنا تمكنا من الحصول على شهادات
حصريه للناجين ولبعض ذوي الضحايا وشهود
العيان كما تحصلنا على مشاهد للطائره
المنكوبه تعرض للمره الاولى
حاولنا التصوير مع اسره الزبير محمد صالح
لكنهم فضلوا عدم المشاركه في الفيلم
اعلنت الحكومه عبر وزير الاعلام والثقافه
احد الناجين من تحطم الطائره ان سبب
الحادثه هو سوء الاحوال الجويه وانعدام
الرؤيه هذا الحادث حدث في داخل مدينه
الناصر
عندما هبطت الطائره في اتجاه الريح فغزف
بها الى داخل البحر
وكل الذين
توفوا
كانت نتيجه للغرض مساء يوم الحادثه كانت
اذاعه المتمردين تعلن مسؤوليتها عن
استهداف الطائره واغتيال الزبير
سمعنا في الاذاعه الحركه الشعبيه قالوا
احنا زادنا طائره اللواء الزبير الحركه
الشعبيه لها ايضا رات يهزبير لانه في 97
استطاعها ان يستقطب مشاعر وياتي بالتفاريت
الخرطوم للسلام واضعف الحركه الشعبيه
[موسيقى]
ومن بعدها ومن بعدها لا نقول وهذا وارد
اثناء التقرب الى الناصر بقت يعني شفنا
المدينه
[موسيقى]
منطقه الناصر في
1998 كانت تتبع لفصيل الناصر وهو الفصيله
كان وقع اتفاقيه السلام
وكان الدكتور
القوات الموجوده كلها كانت تتبع
للدكتور وكانت وقت متوقع اتفاق سلام كان
يريدوا ادعاء البطولات طبعا ولكن في
النهايه برضو الحركه
ساحه الموقف وقالوا انه ما عندهم مسؤوليه
من صدر هذا البيان كان مندفعا ويريد ان
يكسب من وراء مصيبه اصابه ما يسمى العدو
في ذلك الوقت على الرغم من نفي الحركه
الشعبيه مسؤوليتها عن الحادثه الا ان ذلك
فتح الباب لفرضيات استهداف الزبير ومحاوله
تصفيته من دوائر اعدائه
والمتربصين به
ساعه الصفر كانت الساعه اربعه صباحا يوم
27 رمضان اقدم زول اللي هو كان عمر البشير
هرب بيجي اقدم زول في الجيش وهو النائب
الاول الزبير محمد صالح
حصل
الزبير محمد صالح هو مشترك في الجريمه
بتاعه اعدام 28 رمضان
لا احترض على الاعدام ولا احترض على تنفيذ
طريقه تنفيذ الاعدام
تذهب بعض الفرضيات الى تخطيط تنظيم ضباط
الثامن والعشرين من رمضان لاغتيال الزبير
انتقاما لاعدام زملائهم اثر محاولتهم قلبا
نظام الحكم عام
1990 بعض الذين يعني يعني مؤمنين بنظريه
المؤامره يعني يسددون يقاربون ويغيرون
سيناريو ويعني ينسبون هذا الفعل الى فوائد
مختلفه فالان سياسيين مختلفين لتاكيد
نظريه المؤامره والله انا انفي لانه اساسا
الضباط حركه 28 رمضان ما كان عندهم الاليه
اللي يقدروا بها طياره ولا
الاغلبيه اعدموا والبقيه الباغيه كانت في
السين
النفر اللي كانوا بره كله نفرين ثلاثه ما
اكثر من كذا فحركه 28 رمضان بريئه جدا من
طياره الزبير محمد صالح
وعلى الرغم من اعلان الحكومه روايتها
الرسميه الا انه تمت اتهامات تقول ان
تصفيه تمت داخل الطائره
وانه حدث تبادل لاطلاق النار مباشره قبل
الحادثه
[موسيقى]
انا واحد من الناس اللي تناولت الجثمان
بتاع اللي قيمه
[موسيقى]
ولاحظت انه في دم في الصدره الشمال دم
سائل حتى الناس اللي قلت لهم يا جماعه
الانسان ده مستشهد من الصباح وحتى الان دم
مسائل الطبيعي انه الجسمان من هنا يمشي
البيوت يعني كله ميت يودوه لبيته لاهله
النائب رئيس الجمهوريه النائب الجمهوريه
ده مازال عادي ولذلك بالتاكيد ان الجثمان
يمشي لاسرته ويتغسل من جديد
ويتكفى من جديد يعد تكفينه في بيتك
تاني يوم الصباح
لما يعني يقابل جسمان برضو في الساحه
الخضراء للصلاه انا كنت واقف مع الترابي
يعني الترابي صلوا على الجساميل انا
على اليمين وبعد ذلك
للصحافه انا طلعت في البلدوزر واقف في
الراس جهه الراس لحد ما وصلنا المقابر
بتاعه الصحافه في مقابر الصحافه انا واقف
والجثمان نزلوه في القبر برضو الدم موجود
ونفس الكفن بتاع امس موجود وفيما يبدو ان
الكفن ما تغير ولا اتفتح ولا تبدل نفس
الدم في نفس المكان
تذكر بعض الفرضيات ان خلافا حادا وقع بين
الزبير واراكتون ارك ادى لتبادل اطلاق نار
بينهما قبل هبوط الطائره
[موسيقى]
توجهنا الى جنوب السودان لمقابله ابنه
اركون اروك والتي تعتقد ان وفاه والدها
على متن الطائره لم تكن طبيعيه انا بقدر
اقول مدبلج
[موسيقى]
وما يمشي ما يسافر انا الساعه خمسه بعد ما
هو اتغدى منشد
انا انا مسافر
[موسيقى]
مع ناس الحكومه يعني لكن راجل كبير وسياسي
سمعت انه طيب هذا تعليمات العسكري في
الطياره عشان يضرب عرب يعني الحرس
اسمه محمد عبد الله
قالوا
الضرب وكمان ضرب باقي الناس
وفكرنا انه احسن
نعطي حركه السلام الفرصه
حتى
نتمكن من انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
[موسيقى]
فيه
بحكم اتفاقيات خرطوم السلام سنه
ثانيا علاقات ما بين ارض توم و علاقات
مميزه مؤامره مدبره اذا في اطلاق نار
معناه معامله
وفوجئ بها الزبير
طبعا ده كله الحديث ملفق ما له اي اساس من
الصحه انا متاكد
شويه في الطياره انا كان ممكن يكون من
الميتين من ناحيه السياسيه الاختيارات
السياسيه تتم لافراد لكنها لمجموعه كبيره
يعني 57 كلهم يمكن ان يكونوا راحوا ضحيه
يعني
سياسيه لا يستطيع نظام ان يتحمله شو هذا
طلعناهم
مجموعه ما في دول العلويه صار ذخيره ولا
علي واي اثار اطلاق نار يعني
في اصابات قد تكون نشاه من استطاعم
الطياره تحطم الكراسي لكن ما اصابه صغيره
ابدا في الطياره يحمل سلاح فيه ابدا
الاسلحه تطلعنا كلها كانت بدون مخزن
الحقيقه التاريخ غير جامد
والحراك فيه متجدد
ويحرك الساكن والمسكوت عنه والغير واضح
وصراع السياسه
يغصي ويصلح اغتيال في حالات كثيره حتى
يتاح
او يخلو الميدان لمن يغوي او يهوى السلطه
[موسيقى]
تزامنت حادثه موت الزبير مع بدايه خلافات
في المنظومه الحاكمه ما وضع الشيخ حسن
الترابي في دائره الاشتباه
الزبير اول من اعترض على مشروع الترابي من
اجل عوده الاحزاب من اجل الانفتاح
الديمقراطي بيفتكر انه لم يحن الوقت الان
في احد قانون التوالي بفتكر انه ملامح
المشروع الوطني لم تكتمل بعد ويظن وكان
عنده عباره مشهوره يقول الله لا حضرنا
تواليكن ده فهو كان بيعبر عن تطلعات
العسكر لامتداد فتره
الديكتاتوريه اكثر
وعدم الانفتاح الديمقراطي كان هنالك خلاف
حقيقي الذي يلفت النظر في هذا الموضوع عن
الترابي ليس من الشخصيات التي تجنح الى
المؤامرات حوالي سته اشهر من المدافعه
الشديده بينه وبينه ان كان يملكون السلطه
والزبال تحديدا كان مشرفا على الولاد فاثر
في هذا الجانب تاثير شديد لكن الت يتواصل
معهم المعرفه الى الى الى الى الى الشورى
يعني
جمله من القوانين تقتضي حينما الدهر حتى
تتوالد القوانين التي تمثل الدستور واقعا
لا نصا
وحسب حتى اذا عاد المجلس الوطني لدورته
الجديده وجد كل هذه المسودات من القوانين
بين يديه للجيزها كلها دفعه واحده فنحقق
دستورنا كذلك صدقا في الحياه السياسيه لا
نصا
نفاخر به ونشاهير به وحسب
الذي كنت احسه ان كان معزولا كان كان كان
مصوبا
في عمله تجاه قضايا معينه يعني الزبير لم
تكن له صله كان مبعدا عن
علاقته
بالضباطهم
اجتماعاتهم كذلك كانوا بعدا تماما
وليست له ولا ولا يحق له ان يزعل ماذا
يدخله كانت علاقه الزبير بالنظام المصري
تخالف توجهات التراب ومواقفه من القاهره
بل وتشكل تهديدا لاستمرار حكم الجبهات
الاسلاميه في السودان التراب بطبيعه الحال
لم يكن متحمسا للعلاقه مع مصر وهو يعلم ان
مصر لا ترحب باي حكم اسلامي في السودان
وان مصر لم تعطي التراب اي اهميه طوال
تاريخ السياسي لما يكون في توترات بين
الدول
[موسيقى]
بالتواصل بيكون بشخص غير الشخص الاول
الشهيره بتاعتي هو الرئيس حسن مبارك طلب
منا ومنه ما يقعدوا يستريحوا شويه وقعدوا
ثلاثه اربع يوم في في مصر
الرئيس السابق حسني مبارك رحب به ترحيبا
كبيرا وطلب منه ان يموت من الزياره اكثر
وان يبقى في الجلسه المغلقه التي كان
الراس فيها الريح سنو المبارك
تم الحديث عن كيفيه
تقليص او ابعاد او تحيه من النظام
الاسلامي
لم يعد سرا يعني المرحوم عمر سليمان
اللواء كان يقدم مقترحات السياسه اتجاه
السودان وكانت تصب في شيء واحد ضروره
التخلص من الاسلاميين والاسلام السياسي
ودعم الضباط الوطنيين للقيام بدوره وحكم
السودان
اطلقت ترابي تصريحات قيل انها تسببت بخلاف
بين الرجلين قبل حادثه الطائره بايام
ترابي كان لا يترك يعني فرصه في خطاب شعبي
لا يعني استخدمه اللي اجهاض اي محاوله
تقارب بين بين البلدين فبالتالي حدثت انه
فعلا هو اثناء زياره انتقد القياده
المصريه والتوجهات السياسه المصريه لذلك
المساء قدم الترابي مح
[موسيقى]
اضره عن السوداني يملك المياه ويمكن ان
يؤثر على مصر في في ملف المياه وهذا شيء
حيوي جدا بالنسبه لمصر وهذا التصريح فعلا
افسد الزياره
[موسيقى]
تستند فرضيات التصفيه على اصرار التراب
دفن اروكتون اروك في مقابر المسلمين مما
يثير الشكوك عما يريد البعض دفنه مع الجثث
حصل
كنا عايزين ننزل في نفس القبر مع
ناس قالوا نحن ناسرك مشوار
مسيحي ماتت فنون في هذا الجبر حصل صراع
ندفنوا في ناس قالوا مسلمين مع مسلم في
النهايه قالوا اذا مديتونا جسمان نحن
هنشيله للقوه الترابي قال الزول ده مسلم
لانه
عشان كده هم اصروا الاسلاميين عنه الزول
ده مسلم وخلاص يتكفن وكده
ملابسات
وحدث تنازع
وطبعا اسرته وقبيلته كانت ترفض تماما لسبب
انه لم يعلن اسلامه بشكل معلن ومعترف به
ومعروف
وشهاده الترابي لوحدها لم تكن كافيه
دينيه لانه حتى في بيته
عنده كمان مصحفينه وولده بيقول ابونا
المسلمون
احنا كلنا المسيحيين
وهو الشخص
في مقابر المسيحيين ما يدعو الى التساؤل
عن عدم طلب تشليح الجثه من قبل اسرته او
الكنيسه رغم انها الت اليهم في نهايه
المطاف كما لم يقدم احد للسلطه انذاك
اتهاما رسميا ما يضعف فرضيه التصفيه او
الموت المدبر
[موسيقى]
خلال تحقيقنا سعينا لبناء روايه متماسكه
من خلال عدد من شهود العيان على حقيقه ما
حدث من خلال شهاده من كانوا في الطائره
وفي موقع الحادث وللوقوف على حقيقه ما سمح
بنشره من التحقيقات من قبل الحكومه
حضرنا نحن ضباط المحطه وكان قائد الحاميه
العقيد عبد القادر علي محمود ونحن 37
دقيقه او سبعه ونص وقفنا في المدرج وكان
الهواء شديد جدا مدينه الناصر تقع في
منطقه مكشوفه
والفصل كان حينها شتاء وكان الهوى شديد
جدا
انما كنا نقترب من الهبوط راينا ما يشبه
الغبار اثر على الرؤيه
ونحن ننظر من داخل التيار نرى المواطنين
يستعدون لاستقبالنا في مدرج الناصر
وكانت هناك عاصفه او رياح بسرعه اكثر من
العادي
في حوالي الساعه السابعه والنصف صباحا
المحطه
ثم دارت دوره ثانيه
هبطت الى ارتفاع يعني منخفض جدا ويبدو انه
كان الطيار بيحاول يشوف يستكشف المطار
ويشوف المدينه معالم المدينه
اللفه الثانيه اخذ كل كان جنبيه
الزبير رد قال الطير زي الطيار ده يجي من
الجنوب وينزل
من الجمعه
لان المدرج مع متر بس من
ناحيه الشرقيه فبدل يصل شمالا
وهي نازل طولت
اتجاهها الشمال الى الجنوب يعني في اتجاه
مسار الرياح
حتى في زملائنا كان معي واقفين مع هذا
الامر يعني
على انه طيار هبط في التيار الرياح فما
اقدر لانه
الطيار طائره بدت بالهبوط من اول المدرج
في اول المدرج في اقصى الشمال كان في
علامتين برميلين
معلمات باللون الابيض تاجير الابيض هبطت
الطائره من اول المدرج لكن كان سرعته
شديده جدا ومندفع انتفاع شديد جدا في
بدايه اول متر مش عشره متر
من المحبط لكن لانه ده شورت وما عارفين
الحاصل شنو اهبل اول من هبطنا الارزه طبعا
النهر هنا فالضيفات كانت عاليه
يعني منطقه منحذره وليس منطقه صاعده فدي
بتزيد السرعه
في منتصف المدرج بدلا من بدايته في الاصل
الطيار حاول يزيد السرعه يقدر يقلع
طياره دي المفروض تمشي كيلو عندها كيلو
قدامها
صدمه في الهنايه صدمه كده
وقعد في المونه
روايات الشهود والتقارير الرسميه ان
الطائره هبطت في اتجاه الريح مما زاد من
سرعتها لحظه الهبوط فما الذي دفع الطيار
لذلك لما يجيك رجل ويقول لك رجل كان قائد
العامل
وعندنا تاريخ
اصيبت وقتل واستشه سته طيارين وهبطنا في
بدايه المهبط وقفلنا المكانات واستعملنا
البريك كل الاجراءات سليم حسب ما يقول
الكتيب بتاع الطياره بسموه تشيكنست نحن
نعم نفذناكم
قصر المهبط بصوره يعني ما اتوقع انه
بحسب التقرير الرسمي فقد ذكر ان طول
المدرج الترابي
1500 متر وعرضه ثمانيه امتار وان ما
تحتاجه الطائره للهبوط وسبعمائه وخمسون
مترا فقط
اتفتح الباب العلوي الامريكي
وخرج الطيران الاثنين
والمساعد الطيار اللي هم التيار اثنين
والملاح فاتفقنا انا والموسطه
فطلعنا على الجناح الطائره
السلايد عنده مفتوح
انا ماسك موسى المكور ماسك
وانا ماسك في يدي بعدين نحاول في في ناس
من خلف الطياره
ومع التيار
فتذكر من ضمنهم اخونا
والتيار ماشي مع التيار موسى ماسك
الطياره وانا بيديك تاني مسكت حتى مسكت
الحته دي الخلفيه مش انت وسحبته بالنسبه
للطيارين
طلعوا من اول الناس كانوا طلعوا وركبوا في
المراكب قبل البحر الناس المحطه هو الجنود
واقف شايف في شخصي لابس لبس عسكري غطس في
الماء وطلع
ياسر الجيلي اللي هو كان الملاح غطس
السيد اللواء الطبيب الطيب محمد خير
انا لو مسكته ياريته من المويه رفعت في
وقت الطياره الطياره اللحظه دي كانت حددت
في المويه
العسكري
فغطس في الطياره كانت اتملت بعد فتره
وجيزه بدون اكسجين وكده طلع بشخص لابس
جلابيه عرفنا انه ده عبد
السلاميه
طلع الاول اللواء زبير محمد صالح انا مسكت
النائب الاول من من الطياره وفي المركب
وللقيف
ويبدو اليسار مكسوره من اسفل المفصل لحد
ما تخلفه وفي ضربه في راسه هنا حق زي زلطه
كده
وغرقان يعني كان ممتلي بالمويه تماما ما
كان عليه اي اثار غرق
بس كان في كسور في يده واتخذنا من
الارتظام لانه هو طويل
والطائره يعني قصيره مترين للارتفاع بتاعك
كذا وحديد فاحتمال ضرب راسه هنا احتمال
رقبته اتكسرت تختلف الشهادات في وصف جثه
الزبير لحظه خروجها من الماء مما يثير
تساؤلا عن طبيعه وفاته اغلب من كان في
الجزء
الامامي من الطائره
لم يستطيعوا من
الخروج ولذلك استشهدوا في داخل الطائره
منهما
النائب الاول نفسه زبير محمد مصالح
واخرين كان في الوسط
او مايل الجزء الخلفي ليه لانه سؤال
مكانات دايما وصوتها مزعج شويه ما بين
خليهم على الجزء الخلفي شويه
[موسيقى]
فذكر السيد اللواء طيبه ابراهيم الطيب
الاول طلب انه يرجع ورا الطياره شويه عشان
داير يطلب ماذا يسمع الازعاج حق المحركات
الامامي كثير يرجع لورا فودوا الناس
المصاحبين له قدامهم
[موسيقى]
تشير اختلاف وصف شهود العيان لموقع الزبير
داخل الطائره الى ارتباك في بناء روايه
متماسكه حول الحادثه ويلقي غموضا على
حقيقه ما حدث في تلك الرحله
كان قاعد اصلا كان قاعد
عليه كذا
خمسه
من القياده العامه جاءت لنا تحقيق المنطقه
العسكريه انا طبعا مجلس التحقيق مطلع سالم
التفاصيل وكان مفروض ينشر لنا نحن نناقشه
واحنا زمان الحاجه اللي عندنا بنعمل مجلس
التحقيق بتتم اجماع الطيارين والمهندسين
والفنيين وبتبدا مناقشه مجلس التحقيق
وابداء على اراضي التوصل كل الاشياء
الفولية مباشره طوالي يوم 16
فبراير بعد اربعه يوم الفريق حسان
والطيب ابراهيم
بكل التفاصيل بتاعتها وهناك تقريبا موجود
في وزاره الدفاع
التغطيه الدفاع تقرير لاحقا تم تم اعتماده
لان اصلا حاجه قضايا دي انت لازم تعمل
فيها تقرير لن تعمل فيها الحدث
يطلع له بدايته نهايته وبالتوصيلات بتاعته
ضروريه ومساله مهمه
حاولنا الحصول على نسخه من التقارير
الرسميه للحادثه لكن قبل طلبنا بالرفض
لعدم انقضاء المده القانونيه للافراج عن
الوثائق
انا اعرف لينا بواحده فقط هي التي جاوبتني
لما لا ادري باي لجنه اخرى
تم تشكيلها
لتقسي بامر سقوط الطائره في الناصر
الاستنتاج الاخير هو ان هذه الحادثه كانت
نتيجه لخطا
من قبل
الطائره للمجالس التحقيقيه جاءت
تحقق في الموضوع ده
من قراياتهم للعدادات حقت الطائره
والموضوع الفني اذا ذكروا انه الطيار كان
هو في الجهد الفني اللي عمله كان يعني لما
وصل وسط المطار غير يعني غير انه يقوم
بالطياره تاني
وفي واحد في واحد من المحركات دور عامل
فول انجن وفي الثاني من المحرك الثاني ما
شغال ما اشتغل فقال ده هو ربما انه ادى
لسبب
[موسيقى]
تذهب بعض الاتهامات الى ان سبب الحادثه
الرئيسي هو عدم كفاءه طاقم الطائره وان
القرارات الخاطئه التي تم اتخاذها هي التي
ادت بشكل مباشر لسقوطها في النهر فهل تمت
محاسبه الطاقم وهل تم اعلان نتيجه
التحقيقات
[موسيقى]
الكلام ده بيتحدد القوات الجويه ونحن اول
ناس تدربنا على الطائره دي لما جاءت وانا
طيار مقاتل 20 سنه في المقاتلات وخدمته في
الجنوب ده متمركز في جبدي من انا في رده
رائد وقمت بمرحب كثيره جدا وبعد الخرطوم
تحولت الى طائره النقل
واشتغلت
فتره طويله في الاداه في طائرات
الذي حدث بعد ذلك هو ان التحقيقات
المتعلقه بالحادث لم تكتمل ذلك ان اغلب
التجاوزات التي كانت تقع خاصه من
العسكريين بحكم طبيعه النظام لم يكن يكتمل
فيها التحقيق الى الدرجه التي يصدر فيها
احكام بتبرئه جهه او بادانه جهه
لا سيما النزال طاقم الطائره كان قد سافر
في رحله قبل اشهر من حادثه الزبير الى
مدينه واو هذه منطقه اخرى في الجنوب وحدثت
تجاوزات في تلك الرحله وجاءت شكوى من طاقم
البراسم لكن التحقيقات حول الرحله السابقه
لم تكتمل كذلك
كانت الاجراءات الرسميه التي تلت الحادثه
من قبل الحكومه تثير علامات استفهام حول
عدم عرض الجثث على الطب الشرعي وتشريحها
المجلس العسكري مشى وطلع صندوق الاسود
وعملوا مجلس على مستوى عالي جدا نفتكر كان
رئاسه اللواء طيار
ركن عامر الزين الحسن فعلا يتعامل من
الاستحقيق وفعلا في صندوق اسود والحاجات
دي كلها
يعني ما ظهروها لكن كونه ما يظهر مجلس
التحقيق مع نادي هما مدبرين الامر يعني
والذين
في اللجنه هم جزء من التامر من لازم يكون
الحلقه حلقه كامله يعني
لم تكتمل الجهه التحقيقات خاصه حاجز مركز
الذي كان كابتن الطائره بعضا من الشكوى
والتحقيق المتصل به
اتصل الجثانين الى ذوي الضحايا ولم تعرض
على الطب الشرعي لتشريحها وفحصها كما لم
يسمح لذوي الضحايا بمعاينتها مما يثير
علامات استفهام عما اذا كان هناك ما يريد
احد اخفاءه
يغلط على طبيب للتشريح التشريعي
وكان بالضرورات
ان يعلن ذلك الناس
اصلا كان رفضوا
انا صريت اذ تكلمت
لازم انا الوارد يشوفوه
[موسيقى]
طلعوني بس شفتها في يد الشمال ربطه قطعها
اقدرت على
سالته
وفي عيونه دموع وكان
حتى انا
بالطريقه دي
ليه
[موسيقى]
على انه في جريمه
الحادث دي بكل تفاصيلها بكل الدلال كل
المستندات بتاعتها بكل شهود بكل الحضور
بكل الشخصيات بتاعتها هي حادثه حادثه بناء
على نتيجه طبيعيه
وتصرف سواء كان من الطيار او تصرف هندسي
او ايا كان فيها بدون ما يكون هنالك اي
مؤامره عدسه
هؤلاء مع المؤسسه مع جهه المسؤوله وطلقوا
افادات من الجهه المسؤوله حول الاسباب
التقارير التشريح وسقطوا عليها
والدليل انه حتى هذا اليوم
لم نسمع من اي واحد من اسر هؤلاء الضحايا
ان تقدم ببلاغ او تقدم بسؤال
للمؤسسه السياسيه ولا البرلمان ولا حتى
للاعلام بما يعني انه الوقايه او النتائج
التي يخلصوا اليها كانت بالنسبه لمقنعه
وسكتوا عليها
كم
تسحب ثم
كانت البلاد كلها متوتره بعد الحادث
وكانوا في عجله من امرهم يريدون ان يذهبوا
بهذه الجساميل طوارئ
لا اله الا الله
ان تخفي
معالم جرينتك ولن تخطط تخطيط كبير من بين
من كل هذا ان يتم الاعتناء والاهتمام
واقامه
المراسم الاستشهاد وغيرها بصوره في قمه
الابداع والروعه لتخفيه
بالعكس في ذلك الوقت الادبيات كانت تعتبر
كان شهيد للواجب وتم تشييعك شهيد ان
الواجب في ذلك الوقت وتعتبر من اكبر
الجنازات التي يعني شهيدا الناس
كله كان حزين الشعب السوداني ملايين ممكن
تقول عليه وانا اكبر الجنازه شفت اكبر
حاجتي شفته في وداع الشهيد الزبير
[موسيقى]
باستعراض كافه الفرضيات والشهادات ما تزال
بعض الحقائق مرهونه بتحقيقات رسميه لم
يسمح بالكشف عن تفاصيلها حتى الان وفاه
الزبير محمد صالح هي عجلت
بالمفاصله
وخاصه انه الزبير محمد صالح رحمه الله كان
معروف انه كان يمثل نقطه التوازن الذي
يلتقي عليه الطرفان وكان ونزاع الى الحلول
السلميه التوافقيه والله الموت حنس عليه
محل انه يعز البلد ويعز الدين والله والله
شكل رحيل الزبير انفراطا للعقد وغيابا
لصوت كان يجمع الكثيرين
[موسيقى]